this is Despicable what these people are
doing okay but why has this become news
uh this has become news because it it
serves as a deflection it serves as a
deflection it says instead of being
angry about what's going on in in uh the
Gaza Strip what's happening to people
dying instead we're to we're we're
diverted into this uh this particular uh
you know uh despicable act that takes
the pressure off of Israel in effect
this works
to this works as propaganda but you know
you but sure but you know why this
imagery is important why why you see I
think it's very important but what are
they doing with it that's the question
these people these people given the
chance would kill you in your sleep I
don't know that I mean listen I'm not
sure what what does decolonize mean it
means to get rid of the
colonizers how do you do that well I
mean like let's talk about what from
from The River To The Sea means well I
agree with that that's nonsense rhetoric
and I certainly would never uh use